[Musica]
alzi la mano chi crede nella fortuna
probabilmente non andreste d'accordo con
uno degli scienziati più importanti
della storia che in una lettera ad un
suo collega scrisse tu credi che Dio
giochi a dadi col destino Io invece
credo che tutto ubbidisca ad una legge
ben precisa quello scienziato era Albert
Einstein
Eppure sapete io non sono d'accordo con
Einstein Io credo che noi tutti stiamo
costantemente giocando a dadi col
destino
ogni volta è come se stessimo lanciando
dei dadi abbiamo una parvenza di dove
andremo a finire ma non sappiamo mai il
finale per certo
ora
alzi la mano chi farebbe scegliere il
proprio intero futuro ad un lancio di
dadi
Prova a convincervi
e se vi dicessi che potete truccare quei
dadi che potete aumentare la possibilità
che finiscano proprio come volete
che potete imbrogliare il destino
in questo modo giochereste
Quelle foto sono io 18 anni ancora
in un articolo del Sole 24 Ore che parla
dei miei successi
Vi faccio una confidenza
In pochi lo sanno ma per arrivare lì ho
imbrogliato
Sì ammetto candidamente di aver
no non nel senso di scorciatoio
conoscenze particolari Ho puntato
direttamente in grande ho imbrogliato il
destino
Ma come si imbroglia il destino
vedete vengo da una famiglia di avvocati
Sud Italia provincia di Napoli il mio
destino quello di diventare un avvocato
di lavorare nei paesi limitrofi di
limitarmi a quello
i miei amici scherzosamente al liceo mi
dicevano Tu sei l'unico sistemato a vita
avrai
tutte le fortune del mondo farai
l'avvocato e stare bene
il destino aveva scelto
e con il continuo bombardamento di
notizie sulla crisi sul divario nord e
sud e sulla mancanza di opportunità per
i giovani Quella era l'unica scelta
possibile o almeno questo credevo
era il 2022 l'Italia fu chiusa causa
covid-19 in quel momento tutti abbiamo
perso la partita
non lo sapevo ancora ma quella sarà la
prima volta che truccherò i dadi della
mia vita
comprare un libro di giurisprudenza in
preda ad una crisi esistenziale inizia a
capire chi fossi
lo presi Lo lessi
capì che non era la mia strada dopo poco
lo getta nel cestino non volevo essere
quello non volevo essere un avvocato e
non volevo seguire le orme di mio padre
Andai controcorrente Andai contro il
pensiero del paese che mi aveva
cresciuto
non potevo immaginare come quel piccolo
passo avrebbe cambiato la mia vita per
sempre
da lì a poco comprai diversi libri di
diverse facoltà inizia ad informarmi
assaggiai tantissime strade provai di
tutto volevo scoprire chi fossi
mi Inizierò ad appassionare al mondo
delle startup dell'Innovazione della
tecnologia passione
la passione è quella energia quella
forza che non ti fa sentire la
stanchezza
Corri corri ma non senti crampi
inizia a guardare intorno tutti quanti i
miei amici stavano cercando di capire
che strada prendere in quel momento
tutti lanciamo i nostri dati li vedemmo
volare e cadere sui numeri diversi
quello che però non sapevano e che io
stavo imbrogliando stavo lanciando solo
dati da 5 e da 6
un regalo del tempo passato a studiare a
pormi domande
Attenzione anche altre persone
riusciranno a vincere
qualcuno Seguirà le orme dei propri
genitori qualcun altro sapeva già la
propria passione fin da piccolo qualcun
altro ancora si autoconvincerà di averla
trovata per paura di non appassionarsi
ad altro
A me non piace questo approccio perché
in questo modo diamo potere al destino
e magari ci va bene attenzione
o magari ci va male e iniziamo a
navigare nel buio per anni e anni magari
facendo una laurea che non ci piace una
magistrale che non ci piace trovandoci
in un lavoro che non fa per noi
per battere il destino ci sono diversi
metodi e il primo è avere più
informazioni studiare meglio il gioco la
formazione È un modo per truccare i dati
del destino è un modo per aumentare il
numero su quelle facce
più informazioni portano scelte più
consapevoli scelte più consapevoli
portano ad una vita migliore ogni volta
che ci poniamo domande che indaghiamo
noi stessi che indaghiamo le reazioni
tra le cose stiamo truccando i nostri
dati
tutti Giochiamo col destino La
differenza è che chi si impegna può
imbrogliare leggermente e nel lungo
periodo cambiare le cose quindi per
favore ragazzi
sfruttate ogni occasione che avete per
imbrogliare a quei dadi perché vi
cambierà la vita
un po' per caso
con qualche lancio fortunato
aiutato anche dall'impegno mi avvicinerò
ad alcune università milanesi
da libero iniziai a pensare in grande
non succede ma se succede volevo
arrivare sulla Luna
e per me la luna in quel momento era
l'America
La cosa stupenda dei lanci di dadi
e che sono rischiosi ma portano possono
portare tantissime soddisfazioni un
singolo lancio potrebbe truccare
tantissime partite un piccolo passo
nella direzione giusta cambiarvi la vita
le azioni
e questo l'ho capito
portano slancio
portano slancio Nel senso che un singolo
lancio di dadi
crea un effetto Domino quasi invisibile
secondo modo di imbrogliare il destino
allargate la vostra rete di relazioni e
di stimoli provate più cose possibili
siate primo orizzontali assaggiate tante
strade
piccoli investimenti ponderati per
cercare di capire chi siete Cosa volete
fare cosa volete essere
dopo iniziate ad essere verticali ad
impegnarvi per la strada che avete
scelto
io scoprii delle opportunità più grande
della mia vita proprio in questo modo
iniziare a scrivere su LinkedIn alle
persone più variegate
volevo capire cosa fossi cosa volevo
essere
indagai diverse strade assaggiare
diverse strade e poi scoprì
un'opportunità incredibile
quell'università che mi sembrava così
tanto lontana quella dei film quella
della serie TV
era a portata di mano la luna non era
così difficile da raggiungere
se l'impegno può esser visto come
aumentare il numero sulle facce di quei
dadi aumentare la vostra rete di
relazioni e di stimoli e come giocare su
più tavoli contemporaneamente lanciare
più dadi
il destino così è fatto di Casualità di
conseguenza inaspettate
Ma se non giochiamo quella prima partita
nulla di tutto ciò può accadere
inizio a studiare a studiare a studiare
al mio compleanno a Natale a Capodanno
Ero diventato un secchione
ma diamine quanto mi piaceva quella
sensazione quanto mi piaceva quella
sensazione di stare inseguendo un sogno
di avere fame di voler arrivare
in quel periodo proporrò mille progetti
mille iniziative
e anche mille fallimenti
nel mentre nascondo a tutti questo mio
sogno non voglio sappiano
sono insicuro e decido che la mia luna
quell'università era troppo lontana
Harvard era inarrivabile decido di
firmare un contratto con un altro
università sempre americana sempre molto
prestigiosa lo scambio avrei avuto più
possibilità di entrare avrei truccato i
miei dati
però mi sarei dovuto indebitare come
tanti studenti negli Stati Uniti
ed ero disposto a farlo
Quello era il mio sogno in fondo
16 dicembre 2021
aspetto l'una di notte
due anni e mezzo di piante di sofferenza
di lavoro sfrenato
Sto tremando
prendo la lettera di ammissione a quello
dell'università
la apro
siamo spiati
due anni di lavoro
avevo truccato i miei dati il più
possibile mi ero impegnato
[Musica]
e poi siamo spiacenti due righe il mio
sogno era svanito
avevo truccato i dati fino a quel
momento eppure
avevo perso
non volevo sentirmelo dire
ma
lezione anche un dado truccato può farti
perdere
anche impegnandoci al massimo cercando
di aumentare la possibilità di quei dadi
al 100%. non saremo mai sicuri di
riuscire anche imbrogliando si può
perdere È una dolorosa realizzazione non
trovate
impegnarsi così tanto per un sogno e poi
vederlo svanire
anche impegnando ci possiamo perdere È
vero ma questo non ci deve spaventare
la legge di grandi numeri
dice che a ripetere della prova
molteplici volte
il valore si avvicinerà sempre di più al
nostro valore atteso
Cosa significa se noi continuiamo a
lanciare dadi Se continuiamo a truccare
i nostri dadi magari sul singolo lancio
parleremo Ma se imbrogliamo e impariamo
dai fallimenti per imbrogliare ancora
meglio nel lungo periodo saremo
inarrestabile
è una prova di Fede lo so
impegnarsi nel buio senza sapere Non
molte persone ci riescono Però ragazzi
quando si hanno sogni sopra la media e
tutti voi ne avete uno non potete fare
cose nella media per raggiungerli
avevo due settimane 13 application per
aggrapparmi al sogno che avevo un
periodo molto brutto
mio padre non stretta bene Causa covid
finirà in ospedale
Ero distrutto
avevo visto il mio sogno svanire e mio
padre non stava bene
però non era il momento di essere motivo
avevo un sogno e volevo continuarla a
seguire
prendo le mie forze 7 di mattina 10 di
sera tutti i giorni quel due settimane
saranno orribili non le voglio rivivere
ma mi fecero crescere tantissimo
furono davvero molto utili mando tutte
le application
E prendo anche 4 kg
esausto cerco di non pensare a come
sarebbe andata però sei mesi dopo mi
arrivano altre lettere proprio come
quelle di quel dicembre Harvard eale
princeton e tante altre università mi
prendono e mi danno anche una borsa di
studio posso inseguire i miei sogni e
posso farlo senza debiti
lezione quel fallimento si rivelerà la
fortuna più grande della mia vita quel
dicembre 2021
quel dolore è stata la fortuna più
grande della mia vita creerà un effetto
palla di neve che mi farà arrivare in
televisione avere opportunità che è solo
un anno prima erano impensabili andare a
convegni parlare qui oggi
ora tutti festeggiano il mio successo
nessuno era con me in quel dicembre 2021
lezione
si è sempre più soli nella sofferenza
che nella gioia
avevo vinto quel lancio
però la vita è fatta di tanti giochi
e spesso ci troviamo a decidere A cosa
giocare quale tavolo scegliere perché
non abbiamo l'energia di seguire tutto
ma come si fa a scegliere
Su quale gioco investire il nostro tempo
Come si fa a sapere se si è il folle che
insiste Nonostante sia impossibile o si
è l'eroe che insiste nonostante sembri
impossibile
imbroglio numero 3 capisci a che gioco
stai giocando
La vita è fatta di molteplici giochi io
personalmente li divido in due tipologie
i Burroni
un burrone è un gioco molto particolare
e differente dai vicoli ciechi in quanto
cadiamo cadiamo sempre più in basso
arriviamo sul fondo ma poi continuando
ad impegnarci risaliamo prima o poi
riusciamo a risalire quel dicembre 2021
era un burrone era arrivato sul fondo
dove molte persone mollano ma sapevo che
continuando ad insistere
sarei arrivato al mio sogno
dovete però imparare a distinguerli dai
vicoli ciechi i vicoli ciechi sono
giochi che non potete vincere sono
giochi persi in partenza dove forse
esterne stanno toccando i dati meglio di
voi è difficile lo so ma è questo il
ruolo della Formazione cercare di avere
le informazioni per capire in che gioco
state
Ora
concludo raccontandovi la storia del
conformista più importante di tutti i
tempi
come me lui è imbrogliato
come me
è arrivato Dove è arrivato imbrogliando
truccando i dadi
sto parlando di Michelangelo Buonarroti
il pittore rifiutò la Cappella Sistina
Perché lui si reputava uno scultore il
papa insistette insistette tantissimo ma
lui non voleva non era all'altezza aveva
truccato i dati ma aveva paura di
lanciarli
però il destino decise al posto suo
Lancia i dadi al posto suo il papa
continua ad insistere e Michelangelo
alla fine passerà la storia con la sua
cappella Sistina
oltre al merito io sono stato anche
fortunato una particolare luce è caduta
su di me
come Michelangelo
Ho truccato i miei dati però poi ho
avuto la fortuna di lanciarli
ma ora vi chiedo quanti Michelangelo
stiamo perdendo
quante persone non hanno il coraggio di
lanciare quei dadi
quante persone non sono aiutate dal
Destino allo stesso modo
Michelangelo ha toccato i suoi dadi si è
impegnato tantissimo ha migliorato le
sue abilità è entrato nelle Grazie del
Papa le sue possibilità di dipingere
Cappella Sistina erano diverse da quelle
di qualcun altro
e noi lo stavamo perdendo perché non
voleva lanciare quei dati dopo averli
truccati era rimasto l'immobile
imbroglio numero 4
abbiate il coraggio di rischiare una
volta truccati i dati una volta
Impegnatevi per il vostro sogno
lanciateli per favore giocate decidete
di giocare perché sono pochi i giochi in
cui il destino ha deciso di prendere i
rischi al posto del giocatore
non abbiate paura di perdere i dadi non
saranno sempre favorevoli ma a lungo
andare premiranno Chi ha saputo piegare
la fortuna nel proprio senso
ora
imbrogliate toccate i vostri dadi
continuate Impegnatevi non avete paura
dei fallimenti informatevi allargate la
vostra rete di relazioni e stimoli
perché così imiterete grandi della
storia imbroglierete a dadi col destino
è il momento di giocare grazie
[Applauso]
Giovanni D'Antonio Giovanni destino